Welcome back to the David Pakman show. I'm
Benjamin Dixon, filling in for David while
he is away on vacation. Yesterday's Rose Garden
fiasco is the gift that keeps giving, um,
a close up shot of Donald Trump's notes that
he scribbled in order to, um, give that fascinating
speech that he gave yesterday, uh, revealed
that the president of the United States cannot
spell accomplishment. Um, now that's a joke
that works on many levels. I mean there's
layers to that thing. I mean, he can't even
spell accomplishment. Um, and he's not really
racking up the accomplishments, but I'll leave
that to a real comedian. But take a look at
this picture. He actually wrote these things
down. You said, we believed that the president
of the U S has engaged in a cover up, which
is a direct quote from a speaker. Pelosi,
he put a quote most transparent. He wanted
to remind us that, that he was the most transparent,
that they want to impeach me over accident.
They did. I know you are, but what am I a
and then here's the one dems have no, I'll
come lish myths. Alcohol. It looks like it
was smelling alcohol, alcoholism. Um, and
then I'm going to keep working for the American
people. Listen, um, I am very low to, to,
to mock ignorance. Um, you know, no, I'm not.
Who am I fooling? Especially when it comes
to to Donald Trump, like conservatives. This
is your guy. This is your savior. I mean,
here. Here's another thing about this story,
right? All of that rambling he did yesterday
where he was extremely incoherent, extremely
uncouth, made absolutely no sense and should
concern every American person. While most
of us thought it was completely impromptu.
This dude literally wrote notes and, and,
and actually thought about the stuff that
he said yesterday. I could excuse it if it
was an alcohol driven, just rant.
But instead, this is the result of Donald
Trump actually thinking, nevermind the fact
that he can't spell accomplishments. Nevermind.
He smells accomplishments almost as though
he's trying to spell alcoholism. Never mind
all that. The president performance yesterday
in the Rose Garden is the result of him actually
thinking stuff through. What happens when
this man actually just goes off the cuff?
What happens when he just actually, I mean,
wow, there's really nothing else to say about
this other than, holy crap. Look what can
look, what democracy can give us. And I loved
the bankruptcy, but seriously, we've got a
president who actually thinks his stupidity
all the way through to the misspelling of,
I'll call them the commissioners